[Musique]
john hancock la cathédrale saint basile
le bienheureux c'est une vision
merveilleuse le simple fait de la
regarde et vous donne le sourire sa
forme particulière ces bulbes ou colorés
sont incomparables
c'est un lieu d'une grande force
si quelqu'un vient en réussissant
prendre de photos c'est de l'argent
gaspillé autant ne pas venir en russie
[Musique]
c'est un miracle je suis sur le toit
c'est beau en devenir dingue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
enfin bref la cathédrale saint-basile ya
une sorte de gardien de notre esprit de
notre histoire pour moi c'est comme ça
[Musique]
la cathédrale saint basile est toujours
au centre de l'attention mais les
artistes la regarde bien sûr d'une
manière très particulière pour eux elle
n'est jamais là même la lumière change
les perspectives sont diverses les
possibilités artistiques qu'elle offre
sont infinies mais la cathédrale
n'attire pas seulement les artistes
des politiciens aux athlètes des stars
d'hollywood aux musiciens tant de
célébrités de ce monde sont venus ici
cet emplacement devant saint basile est
très apprécié c'est là qu'un mouchoir et
nigar et le groupe pink floyd se sont
fait photographier
la promenade des candidats de miss
univers devant la cathédrale a aussi été
mémorable
il n'était pas facile de savoir quoi
regarder
[Musique]
la cathédrale saint-basile monument
emblématique de la capitale russe
l'élément architectural russe le plus
célèbre et le plus reconnaissable monde
prendre un seul fille devant la
cathédrale saint basile est un must pour
tout voyageur
[Musique]
certains disent que c'est la fantaisie
d'un confiseur fou drôle d'association
pour d'autres cela fait écho cathédrale
gothique et il y en a même qui voient
une ressemblance avec le taj mahal
[Musique]
on
je la vois chaque fois d'un oeil
différent je veux dire ce n'est pas
simplement voilà saint basile et c9
bulbes à chaque fois c'est comme si je
la voyais pour la première fois je veux
la détailler de plus en plus
tout le monde a vu cet édifice au moins
une fois dans sa vie dans les livres les
albums sur des pièces de monnaie sur
instagram ou dans de nombreux films sur
la russie mais le voir de vos propres
yeux est une autre histoire
quand les touristes viennent à moscou la
première chose qu'ils font et de se
rendre sur la place rouge et à saint
basile
en effet tout le monde la connaît même
si tout le monde ne connaît pas son vrai
nom si un touriste vous approche sur la
place rouge et vous demande où est la
cathédrale de l'intercession vous vous
demanderiez ce qu'il veut dire où par
exemple la cathédrale de l'intercession
sur le fossé pas clair non plus mais sur
le cartel vous verrez que l'église porte
vraiment le nom de cathédrale de
l'intercession de la très sainte mère de
dieu sur le fossé la cathédrale a deux
noms l'officiel qui lui a été donné par
le métropolite macaire juste après sa
construction c'est la cathédrale de
l'intercession de la très sainte mère de
dieu sur le fossé l'autre lui a été
attribué par le peuple saint basile le
bienheureux
c'est la plus belle cathédrale saint
basile c'était un simple l'église pour
son nom aujourd'hui sans l'aide d'un
guide touristique peu de gens peuvent se
souvenir de l'événement en l'honneur
duquel ce chef-d'oeuvre a été construit
la cathédrale a été construite sur ordre
d'ivan le terrible pour célébrer la
victoire sur le canal de kazan
il est intéressant de noter que nous
avons oublié la victoire sur le canal de
kazan c'est comparable à la victoire
dans la grande guerre patriotique au 20e
siècle c'est un énorme bouleversement
qui a assuré à la russie d'accès à la
sibérie la russie a doublé son
territoire sous ivan le terrible
c'est difficilement imaginable
aujourd'hui
il ya eu trois campagnes militaires
importantes deux d'entre elles ont
échoué et seule la troisième celle de
1552 a été couronnée de succès avant
cette campagne victorieuse
ivan iv a fait le voeu d'ériger un
monument en cas de victoire donc la
cathédrale de l'intercession en tant que
monument était destiné à être élevée et
après la victoire et ça a été le cas
[Musique]
les faits historiques n'empêche pas les
gens de spéculer sur des détails
des bulbes de la cathédrale je ne sais
pas à quel point c'est vrai mais andy
qu'ils ont été apportés de kazan d'ivan
le terrible les a emportés ce sont
probablement les coupole de la mosquée
cool sharif
ce n'est évidemment pas vrai mais c'est
une théorie intéressante la principale
idée qui courent parmi les touristes
visitant la place rouge et que la
cathédrale saint basile est une seule
église
en réalité elle en comprend 11 c'est en
quelque sorte une offre spéciale de la
part de son fondateur ivan le terrible
pour un ticket acheté 11 églises visiter
[Musique]
plus tard en 1672 s'entend après la fin
de la construction de la cathédrale
principal une nouvelle église a été
ajouté
elle est plus difficile à trouver parce
qu'elle n'a pas de dôme
et d'églises d'yvan le bienheureux
construite au dessus de la tombe du
saint
tous ceux qui visitent la cathédrale de
l'intercession ne peuvent manquer ce
monument minines et polarski qui sont
pour les russes ce que jeanne d'arc est
pour les français le
monument ne sait pas toujours trouver à
cet endroit avant d'être déplacé en 1931
il se trouvait au milieu de la place
rouge
il gênait vraiment les bolchéviques le
monument en bronze a failli être fondue
c'est joseph staline lui même qui l'a
sauvé ce serait apparemment sa propre
décision de ne pas envoyer la statue au
four et de la déplacer plus près de la
cathédrale saint basile
[Musique]
le nomme de nijni novgorod mini déposera
ce qui se tiennent désormais juste
devant cette célèbre cathédrale donc
comme on dit aujourd'hui ils sont
maintenant à la mode ils sont là pour
rester et ne quitteront plus cette place
sauf pour des travaux de restauration un
saïfi de vente e est un élément
indispensable du programme culturel de
touristes
[Musique]
si vous voyez constamment des touristes
autour de la cathédrale saint basile
vous pouvez peut-être aussi rencontré
des archéologues il travaille
constamment sur le site il étudie les
fondations de l'édifice
[Musique]
savions pas exactement comment les
fondations avaient été disposés parce
qu'il vient souvent un écart entre la
conception d'un projet et sa réalisation
des fondations former un rectangle mais
ne sont pas exactement orientées comme
les l'édifice lui même il ya un petit
décalage
l'édifice a été construit ici sont axa a
été un peu décalée
en 1931 l'année où le monument à
déménager toute la place rouge a été
rénové même les pavés ont été remplacés
ici nous nous tenons sur une section
pavée vraiment unique
c'est le premier pas vraiment avoir été
posées sur la place rouge
qu'il est composé de petites pierres de
différentes formes ce sont leurs formes
naturelles
[Musique]
vous pouvez également voir des lignes
plus clairement défini qui sont formés
par des pierres plus grosse
on estime que le premier pavé de moscou
est apparu sur la place rouge en 1804
lors de la première rénovation majeure
de moscou dans les années 30 non
seulement le monument a été déplacée
mais les pavés ont également été changés
la plus importante place du pays compte
plus de 2 hectares d'espacés ouverts
c'est comme si les constructeurs avaient
prévu la charge que devrait subir ces
pierres
résistant et polie à la perfection par
les chaussures des touristes ces pavés
ont été posées et s'il ya plus de 100
ans
chaque page est été coupé à la main
c'est pourquoi ils ont tous des formes
différentes
imaginez qu'un carreau de 10 cm sur 20
peut supporter jusqu'à 30 tonnes
donc aucun défilé où chars ne peuvent
endommager il n'y a que trois gisements
de cette roche sur la planète celle ci
vient de carélie
de nombreux secrets et légendes
entourent l'histoire de la rénovation de
la place rouge selon une de ces légendes
nous avons failli perdre la cathédrale
saint-basile à cause d'un haut
fonctionnaire du parti
laser kaganovitch a montré à staline un
modèle de la place rouge modifié où il
n'y avait pas de cathédrale staline a
remis le modèle de la cathédrale édiles
hazard ne la touche pas
bien sûr on ne sait pas si cette
conversation a vraiment eu lieu mais
l'église ait survécu aux moments les
plus difficiles saint basile donne un
sentiment de joie et de chaleur
après avoir visité la cathédrale
beaucoup rêvent de revenir ici
j'étais venu visiter la cathédrale
certains je me promenais tout autour et
je me souviens avoir fait un voeu et
environ huit ans plus tard mon voeu a
été exaucé donc pour moi c'est une
cathédrale magique
non eh bien ça ressemble à la maison
d'un magicien ça semble peut-être un peu
enfantin ce que je dis mais je pense que
six heures magicien avait un château il
ressemblerait à cette église
c'est une source d'inspiration je pense
que je pourrais peindre et reproduire
sans cesse ses ornements
bien sûr je veux partager toute la joie
qui s'accumulent en mois pour
transmettre aux autres ma bonne humeur
et l'énergie que je ressens
de nos jours le chemin vers l'église
passe également par l'espace numérique
l'envi de communiquer avec les visiteurs
en ligne est tout aussi grande que dans
la réalité ces comptes sur les réseaux
sociaux ont des abonnés en provenance de
toute la planète
c'est un excellent moyen de promouvoir
des événements dans nos musées comme le
concours des 460 de pâques
nous avons reçu d' incroyable
interprétation de nos éléments
architecturaux et ornements que les gens
ont utilisé pour décorer des
bisons annoncé un concours consacré à la
cathédrale saint basile alors je me suis
mis au travail
ça m'a pris un mois et demi j'étais prêt
à abandonner tout le reste le monde
semble s être arrêté pendant que j'étais
plongé dans mon travail bien sûr cela
m'a donné tant de plaisir je ne serai
pas comment l'expliquer j'étais
extatique
je ne voulais pas faire une
représentation classique de saint basile
mais proposer quelque chose de
totalement nouveau
popeye fait craindre aux salomon inspiré
et ont servi de base pour les peintures
sur les oeufs de pâques que j'ai conçu
pour le concours il me semble qu'ils
sont vraiment incroyables
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya un motif
cosmique dans cette histoire parce que
même la gamme des couleurs fait penser à
l'espace aux étoiles
l'oeuvre de nadejda est arrivée la
première place et cet oeuf de pâques
fait désormais partie de la collection
du musée
[Musique]
c'est génial c'est vraiment merveilleux
parce que mes travaux sont exposés au
musée des pièces que j'ai fait de mes
propres mains juste à côté d'objets des
18e et 19e siècles
donc mon travail se retrouve sur un pied
d'égalité avec des pièces fabriquées par
des maîtres il y a deux cents ans c'est
génial
c'est ici qu'on commence à faire
connaissance avec la cathédrale voilà
l'église de basile le bienheureux qui a
été construite après la mort du fol en
christ dont les miracles sont devenues
légendaires ces reliques se trouve ici
on peut dire que basile le bienheureux
garde toujours le site le plus sacré de
moscou vous ne pouvez accéder au musée
sans franchir le seuil de l'église
les gens venaient rendre visite à saint
basile d'où le nom de cathédrale
saint-basile un homme simple un faux
lent christ qui était proche du peuple
ils défendent est la vérité et à gagner
l'amour auprès des gens
il est assez difficile d'expliquer de
nos jours à quelqu'un qui sont ces
folles en christ dans la tradition
orthodoxe
les bienheureux ou plutôt qu'il était au
16e siècle ce que nous savons sur saint
basile c'est qu'il déambulait dévêtue
n'avait pas de maison il a renoncé à
tout consciemment à l'âge de 16 ans
quand il était presque adulte il est
allé vivre sur la place rouge comme ça
pour ces privations le senior la
récompense est là doté de la capacité de
faire des miracles de guérir et de
clairvoyance
donc basile le bienheureux est devenu
célèbre pour ses miracles près des
moscovites
on dit même que le tsar ivan le terrible
le craignais
autour de la cathédrale et de son
principal maître d'ouvragé le tsar ivan
iv il ya toujours eu beaucoup de
légendes ivan le terrible dit on aurait
tué son fils on en a la confirmation
avec la peinture dorée pin mais aussi
qu'il aurait fait aveugle et les
architectes de la cathédrale pour que
personne ne puisse créer une autre
merveille de ce type
nous n'avons rien contre le fait que la
cathédrale de l'intercession soit
l'objet de légende
cela est d'attirer l'attention sur le
monument ce qui implique que des gens
viennent examiner son architecture ce
bel panne sur murale son exposition
historique
grâce à elle le plus grand nombre de
personnes s'intéressent à l'église en
elle-même
la cathédrale saint basile et d'une
éblouissante de beauté mais ce n'est
tout de même pas assez pour ordonner de
crever les yeux de ses architectes cette
légende est devenu extrêmement populaire
grâce à un écrivain
je vous rassure tout de suite ce n'est
qu'une légende
nous ne savons même pas qui était ce m
en outre il n'existe aucune source
historique confirmant les informations
selon lesquelles ses maîtres auraient
été tués en russie à l'école cette
histoire s'est répandue avec une oeuvre
de dimitri qu'edwin
il s'agit de son poème architectes où il
est décrit en détail comment ces pauvres
architectes aurait été aveuglé
et c'est seulement dans les années 1920
que les gens en russie ont commencé à
avoir pitié de ces bâtisseurs
à la fin du 19e siècle l'archiprêtre de
la cathédrale de l'intercession trouve
dans une source écrite des preuves que
deux maîtres russes posnic et barma ont
construit le miracle architectural c'est
alors que ces noms sont entrés dans
l'histoire tout le monde dit que ces
deux architectes et il s'agit des
architectures russe posnic et barma ont
édifié la cathédrale de l'intercession
voici la chronique authentique elle se
trouve ici dans la cathédrale l'icône de
basile le bienheureux ce n'est pas
seulement une image d'un saint on peut
voir à quoi ressemblait la place rouge
au 16e siècle
[Musique]
le long des murs de la forteresse le
paysage était complètement différent
il y avait un pont reliant la tour
spasskaïa à la place rouge de nos jours
vous ne le trouverez pas ici le pont
passe au dessus d'une bande bleue c'est
à dire au dessus de l'eau et là aussi il
n'y a plus d'eau sur la place rouge
aujourd'hui mais il ya eu de l'eau
pendant longtemps depuis le début du
xvième siècle jusqu'au début du 19e
siècle il s'agissait d'une douve d'un
fossé est encore aujourd'hui on peut le
voir dans le nom nous l'appelons la
cathédrale de l'intercession de la très
sainte mère de dieu sur le fossé même si
le fossé a été comblée car il ne servait
plus
ils longeaient le mur est du kremlin de
la rivière moskova jusqu'à lanig line hi
ha et servait de fortifications
défensives c'est à dire que le temple se
trouvait au bord du fossé qui mesurait
par endroits 30 4 mètres de large
quand j'ai commencé à utiliser les
ornements de cette cathédrale
j'ai cherché un angle inhabituel sous
lequel personne ne l'avait fait
auparavant
sur internet j'ai réussi à trouver une
photographie prise de hauteur et j'ai
finalement compris comment la dessiner
bien sûr je voudrais le voir de haut de
mes propres yeux dans un ballon
peut-être ou d'une autre manière je ne
sais pas
où s'il était possible de monter sur le
toit d'un bâtiment voisin ce serait
formidable
extrait ville de chelles pourquoi nous
cessons la
[Musique]
cathédrale saint basile est à la fois un
musée et une église pendant les grandes
fêtes orthodoxes des services religieux
s'y déroulent
à ces moments là la cathédrale prend vie
ce n'est que pendant les services que
cela est possible
vraiment on plonge dans une autre époque
et on peut imaginer comment se dérouler
les messes au milieu du xvième siècle
des centaines de personnes viennent ici
pour les liturgies des centaines ici la
grâce de dieu et présente d'une manière
particulière et touche le coeur de
chaque personne
la cathédrale saint basile a déjà plus
de 450 ans nous connaissons la date
précise des premiers services religieux
au milieu du xxème siècle au cours des
travaux de restauration une inscription
a été découverte sous plusieurs couches
de peinture dans la voûte de l'église
centrale il a fallu plusieurs années
pour que la date exacte de la
consécration de la cathédrale soit
révélée
c'est l'anniversaire de l'église de
basile le bienheureux
[Musique]
étonnante ces inscriptions contiennent
des informations sur la date
d'achèvement des travaux de construction
il est dit que la cathédrale a été
consacrée le 12 juillet 1561 le jour de
la fête des saints pierre et paul elle a
été consacrée par la metropolit macaire
en présence d' ivan le terrible et de
ses deux fils ivan est fait d'or
[Musique]
dans les murs de la cathédrale de
l'intercession vous pouvez entendre des
gens par les différentes langues mais il
n'est pas nécessaire de traduire les
manifestations d'émerveillement sonne
pareil dans toutes les langues
[Musique]
l'atmosphère l'ambiance ce qui est à
l'intérieur les couleurs c'est
époustouflant c'est différent de ce que
vous voyez en photo
avec toutes ses couleurs et tout ça en
réalité ils avaient l'impression que
tout cela vit
au qatar la plupart des gens connaissent
la cathédrale saint basile parce que
c'est l'endroit le plus emblématique de
russie il met même l'image de cette
église sur les cartes postales comme
symbole de la russie
disparaissant dans les angles se
baissant pour ne pas se cogner la tête
contre les voûtes des touristes qui
déambulent toute la journée
[Applaudissements]
quand les visiteurs montent au premier
étage beaucoup demandent s'ils peuvent
aller encore plus haut
vous vous imaginez ce qu'ils ont déjà vu
ne leur semble pas suffisant ils ont
l'impression que notre compte du milieu
de xvième siècle n'auraient pas de faim
qu'ils vont tourner à un tel endroit et
qui vont découvrir un tout nouveau décor
ce sentiment nous est familier
nos visiteurs veulent que ce plaisir
esthétique qu'il prenne à examiner ces
magnifiques peintures murales perdure
l'intuition du tourisme ne se trompe
jamais en fait le con tu continues
mais pour le voir comme au temps des
légendes russe il faut traverser des
épreuves tout le monde ne peut pas se
faufiler ici un passage étroit dans la
demi-obscurité et enfin la lumière tant
attendu
peu de gens ont la chance de voir les
bulles de l'église de si près
si elles sont à portée de main coloré
comme un pain des pistes de noël
[Musique]
de là on voit bien le clocher c'est le
onzième dôme de la cathédrale de
l'intercession mais il a été construit
sans ans plus tard
[Musique]
le carillon des cloches est un autre
cadeau pour les touristes on ne l'entend
pas tous les jours mais beaucoup
viennent précisément pour l'écouter
nous lui aussi en russie la musicalité a
suivi un double chemin le coeur et les
cloches en occident il y a le coeur et
lord alors que la russie a développé les
coeurs et les cloches
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au sommaire
même si la cathédrale est un musée il
doit y avoir un coeur tout le monde
connaît l'acoustique formidable des
églises et plus le bâtiment est vieux
plus on a de chance d'entendre quelque
chose d'unique vous trouverez peu
d'églises à moscou qu'ils soient plus
ancienne que la cathédrale saint basile
le bienheureux
les gens réagissent différemment
certains sont marqués par le fait qu'ils
entendent pour la première fois des
chants religieux ils en ont peut-être
entendu à la télévision mais ici c'est
réel cependant chaude que d'autres
voudraient nous applaudir mais se font
parfois timides et demandent si c'est
interdit c'est plutôt un concert donc
nous sommes heureux si cela crée des
émotions
la véritable épreuve a été en 2018 avec
la coupe du monde des gens sont venus du
monde entier et chacun a réagi à sa
manière les habitants du nord sont
réservés les mexicains et les latino
américains sont différents c'est très
curieux mais tout le monde a fait preuve
de beaucoup de respect aux chômeurs
jeunes
la cathédrale saint basile le
bienheureux est devenu un des symboles
officiels de la coupe du monde de foot
2018 et en matière de visites de
touristes étrangers elle a même dépassé
le stade de loudes micky ou des matches
de l'épreuve ont eu lieu notamment la
finale
lors de la coupe du monde il y avait une
incroyable ferveur
[Musique]
toute la rue nichols caillassé
transformer en un défilé international
nous avons vu des mexicains avec leurs
sombreros nous avons vu des brésiliens
des gens de tous les pays et évidemment
il ne pouvait pas partir sans prendre de
photos devant la cathédrale parce que
pour tout le monde c'est une carte de
visite de la russie c'est sûr
tout le monde se souvient avec une
grande joie de ses rencontres c'était
une fraternité humaine tout le monde
essayait de vous aider même ceux qui ne
parlent pas anglais ou d'autres langues
étrangères ont trouvé le moyen
d'expliquer où allaient
les dom de la cathédrale et des tas se
repérer car chacun d'eux est unique
les touristes les compare souvent aux
écailles d'une pomme de pain parfois un
ananas ou un artichaut et voici un petit
conseil pour l'avenir au cas où vous
auriez peur de vous perdre
il est tout simplement impossible de se
perdre sur la place rouge
principalement parce que le temps peu de
basile le bienheureux est une boussole
en soi est très facile à utiliser vous
avez besoin de vous déplacer vers le
nord le double vous montre la direction
si vous voulez aller vers le sud
orientez-vous sur le rouge la preuve
[Musique]
peu importe où vous allez vers le nord
ou vers le sud la cathédrale saint
basile le bienheureux vous montrera la
voie elle réalise les rêves de tous ceux
qui en sont amoureux
c'est un miracle je suis sur le toit
et donc c'est bon en devenir dingue
[Musique]
yacast sport parle de coup droit il me
semble que tout artiste tout photographe
même toute personne ordinaire aurait
beaucoup donné pour se retrouver ici sur
ce toit pour voir de cet angle la
cathédrale la place rouge et tout ce qui
est autour de moi en ce moment
cela procure tant d'émotions que les
mots me manquent pour exprimer tout ce
que je ressens
je ne peux même pas dessiner mes mains
tremblent je suis submergé par les
émotions j'en ai le souffle coupé et
donc voilà
[Musique]
les portes de la cathédrale sont
toujours ouvertes pour tout le monde
c'est peut-être pour ça qu'elle attire
tant inutile de la présenter elle vous
restera à jamais en tête
[Musique]